Freak bitches
now what about,
uh,
other kinds of therapy,
like a cold therapy,
ice bass,
cryotherapy,
things on those events.
Prolotherapy,
stem cell,
platelet injections.
If you could think of.
I've done it.
I wouldn't even get in.
I don't want your cat and your readers
to hear everything I've done because they
would probably have me locked in.
Like what have you done that
would have you locked up?
I've used our stint and
strict nine injections.
What?
Strychnine strychnine or
arsenic and strychnine try.
Why would they inject you with poison?
Because it raises your
red blood cell count.
I've used nitric cushion cream,
natural glycerin cream because you know,
in a stimulate blood flow and me and
start your heart up and I use it because I
broke my back and I didn't want to
admit I broke my back a second time.
So I use it.
I told my friend who was a
professor at Iowa state and says,
don't go nowhere to see what his dust.
I mean I was raised to
beat for three hours.
I felt like you were hitting
me in the head every,
every heartbeat.
Just hit me in a temple and uh,
so,
but I've done it all.
There's nothing I haven't tried.
I did lectric statement was,
it's called a microwave in
linkedin up the muscles.
I'm Tom did it for what,
15 seconds?
I did it for 96 minutes.
What does it do?
It lengthens out the muscles.
Leary straighten out your
leg right off the ground.
Electrocuting you and uh,
for six minute segments.
And I did 96 minutes.
So it's electrical muscular
stimulation pads lengthens it.
So,
and I should never done it because
I think I've got too many injuries,
you know.
And um,
it basically tore.
It popped my,
uh,
my hips and my children's out of socket
pop my hip bone right here.
My hipbone you're crazy.
Your whole body is like a
walking medical encyclopedia,
you know,
you got to try it.
Right.
And that's me basically
geeking out on the decks.
Yeah.
So,
and then Tony Trim,
which is a Dj that
travels with him was like,
oh dude,
you can just get this and
you can just buy this stuff.
And that's what really got
me to do it was girl one up,
let's look at that white guy dance move.
We'll do that move.
You're doing there.
You're doing this.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
Just listening to you.
What really geeked me out.
But the name Dj Dad math came because he
was becoming a father at the time and I
was like,
you're like way lane bro.
Me a dad.
And then it kind of
morphed into Dj data are.
But taking it onto morning news was
funny.
That was so fun.
And I was like all the time,
you know.
So when you went on as a onetime goof,
did you have a plan or
did you just not really.
I was just like,
the fun thing was to go was because I,
the thing that I hate the most we do.
They're like,
what can audiences expect this weekend?
They always say that,
oh,
I hate that.
And I'm like,
fucking show jokes.
What do you talk about?
Yeah,
what's,
what's bothering you right now,
Tom?
Yeah,
that's the setup.
Tell what's going on in your life and
they think you just go there and then they
go,
just do whatever you want.
Like just have fun with it.
So when they do that I was just like,
it's not really,
I don't really give a fuck about comedy.
And then they were like,
what?
I'm like,
it's about the after party,
you know,
I'm gonna be deejaying and why I'm here.
Just to goof on them.
Like,
yeah,
because it was fun to
have fun and be like,
all right,
you are at the funny bone.
Right?
I'm like,
I mean for a minute,
I don't even really care about it.
The funny bone.
And then you have the funny bone
sitting right there off camera.
Like
who cares?
Like the best part is when he sets up
like the really cheesy anchors to ask him
stupid questions.
Like did you,
oh you had someone do
the bird is fat thing.
That was the best one because you know,
if you ever add sometimes when you go,
hey,
um,
you know,
asked me about farts or something,
they'll be like,
like,
so they,
they know not to.
They,
they,
they check themselves on asking something
provocative or that's not 100 percent
pg,
so I didn't know how it would go,
but I go,
oh,
asked me my bird,
so fat and the lady goes,
okay,
and then so we just are in
the middle of this interview
and she goes,
White Bird,
so fat.
And I was asked a good
question and I'm like,
I just rolled with it,
you know,
and then it grew.
And then a hot dog eating champion,
a guy that was in Scotland,
she placed tinny place.
Yeah,
he's like one of the,
he was like a super competitive eater,
like a Kobiashi dude.
This guy was assigned
to the audio on this.
It's incredible
life changing stuff.
Um,
I've dropped about 100
pounds in eight months.
He dropped 100 pounds my
cheat day for the year,
but prepping just this amazing water
which to giant inspirations first.
My wife second anniversary today.
So I want to say hi to her.
And um,
there's a comedian I love,
he's a big,
giant fat guy just like me,
Bert Chrysler,
he's still way bigger than I am.
Maybe I can inspire him.
We were talking about this woman,
we didn't talk about too much,
but we should.
This woman who was the woman that Hillary
Clinton brought up during the trump
debate because she was saying that Donald
Trump humiliated this woman because he
shamed her and humiliated her because she
gained weight while she was a missile.
Olympia.
I miss this.
I was in the bathroom
and you guys had this.
She got up to 170 pounds
according to trump.
She went up from like 1:22,
one slash 70.
According to him,
probably not right.
Probably gained like 30 pounds.
But apparently she really
did gain a fuckload of way.
And um,
and Hillary Clinton made this big
deal about like how awful it was.
He did that to her and then they had
these commercials already planned for the
next day.
So they launched these
commercials the next day.
And in the commercials
they show this woman,
she's speaking in Spanish.
You're talking about
Donald trump is terrible.
What he do to me.
He made me feel bad.
He made me.
He was scared.
So then after that comes out,
people start researching her,
they find out that she drove
a getaway car in a murder,
that she threatened to judge because the
judge who is going after her boyfriend
at the time that she
drove the getaway car,
she threatened the judge,
said that she was going to kill the judge.
She had an elite,
a illegitimate baby with a
Mexican kingpin drug dealer.
All of the Mexican drug cartel kingpins
came to the baby's Christening.
Then she went on,
big brother,
big brother.
She was engaged in some baseball player,
went on big brother and fuck some other
guy on the show while the cameras were
on her and she was yelling out in
Spanish that he has a magnificent coffee.
Wow.
The same lady that I
used in our commercial.
So then they have her on CNN.
My.
So
Anderson Cooper interviews on CNN and
Anderson Cooper says some people are
saying that you threatened to judge
and that you drove a getaway car.
Like,
is this yours?
Everybody having pass.
Okay,
I'm not angel.
I'm not a bad person.
But they're trying to take
away from what he did.
What he did was wrong.
Okay.
What I did was 20 years ago,
what he did was 20 years ago
to all he did was coming,
but in his defense she probably was.
She got fat,
so there's pictures of her.
She definitely got fat,
but you know,
ordinarily that's a very rude thing to do,
but when your job is to be
a professional hot chick,
it's like if you just decide,
say like if you're a model
for like a shaving cream,
like have you like your,
your whole thing is about your
legs and you're showing your legs.
I touched the mic,
sorry,
but your thing is about your sleek,
smooth legs and you're like,
fuck it.
I'm letting these bitches grow.
And everyone's like,
hey,
you can't do your job is to have sleek,
smooth legs.
No,
it's not that you're known
for your nice flakes.
Yeah.
She's known for being a professional,
attractive woman.
Any holiday he shouldn't objectify women.
That is the whole point of being Muslim.
So Hillary paid her to obviously if she's
in an anti trump commercial than that
means hillary paid her right.
Um,
might not be
money.
It might just be attention because it
gave her the opportunity to get back in
the limelight and apparently
she's a giant attention whore.
Gotcha.